Hi, yeah, thanks, it's great to be here.
It's a privilege to be speaking to you today,
I'm really excited to share with you
my thoughts around WebAuthn.
And why we should start forgetting about passwords.
My name is Ben Dechrai.
I've been a software engineer now for about 20 years,
just over 20 years.
And my passion has always been around security and privacy.
One of the things that really excites me about WebAuthn
is that we live in a world nowadays
where it's quite common to outsource
all of the authentication to a cloud provider
like Auth0, who will allow you to integrate
an SDK with your application and get login
and single sign on and multifactor authentication,
all these mechanisms out of the box.
But the credentials are all stored in one place.
Now arguably, it's better to give that to a company
who is dedicated to making sure that it's secure,
but WebAuthn helps us one step further
by making sure that the credentials can't actually be
leaked at any point
because they exist on these tiny little devices
or in your phones or on your laptops.
So the hardware authenticators become the mechanism
that prove your credentials,
rather than remembering a password for example.
So I think the future of WebAuthn
is that it's going to make our lives as users
a lot easier and our lives as developers
and even the infrastructure side of things
a lot less stressful, so it can only be a good thing.
Before we have a look in depth at what WebAuthn is
and how it works, let's look at passwords
and other credentials,
lets look at the characteristics that we look for
in sets of credentials and work out where they sit,
how they relate to each other
and what the pros and cons of each are.
So, when I look at a set of credentials,
there are three main groups of characteristics
that I look at to work out whether or not
I think it's a good performing,
a well performing credential set.
The first thing is, is it easy to use?
Is it easy to remember?
Is it going to be hard for somebody else to guess?
Or in the case of where it's not something that's guessable,
it can can be easily cloned.
The second thing is, how easy is it to change?
If somebody does manage to guess my password for example,
how easy can I change it?
If somebody manages to get access to my phone,
how easily can I change it?
The change mechanisms is really important.
But if it's really easy to remember, and hard to guess,
and really easy to change,
those two by themselves don't help,
if they're also easy to intercept.
So obviously, we want any credential mechanism
to be hard to intercept.
So if it's hard to intercept, if it's easy to change
and if it's easy to remember and hard to guess,
then it's a good set of credentials.
Let's have a look at some of these credentials
and see how they stack up.
I'm going to use a very non scientific mechanism here,
basically, to plunk onto a graph,
the performance that I think that each of these
credential types have
with the correct characteristics that we've just looked at.
I'm basically going to say
that they either perform really well really badly
or somewhere in the middle,
i.e. "is it a bit of a gray area situation?"
And I've mentioned passwords already, let's start there,
because that's a credential mechanism
that we're all familiar with.
Usually tied with a username or an email address
a password is something we have to remember,
which means that they're increasingly
or significantly hard to use
in terms of how easy it is to remember.
They're also somewhat easy to guess insofar as,
if I have a password that's easy for me to remember then
it's either going to be one of many passwords
that are quite common,
or the length of the password is going to be
such that a computer could iterate through
and do a brute force attack and get to it
relatively quickly.
The easier it is for me to remember a password,
the easier it is for a computer or a human
to generate or guess that password.
The ease of change though,
is something that passwords are probably the best at,
which is not necessarily a saving grace for passwords,
it's just a fact
that a password is basically is stored in a database
or in some kind of storage mechanism somewhere.
Ideally, it's gonna be hashed
so that it can't be reverse engineered from the hash.
But to change a password
just requires you to prove your identity
and then provide a new password which will then get hashed
using the same mechanism and stored in the database table.
So it's basically, it's the hash and a database update
and that's all it's technically required
to perform a password change.
So changing a password, really easy.
Intercept is, I'm gonna put it
slightly down towards the negative side of the gray area.
It's becoming a lot harder to intercept because nowadays,
we're a lot more focused on HTTPS everywhere.
It's more common to find even your standard blog
that doesn't even require you to log in to view it,
will still be able to reach HTTPS.
And there are various other reasons why we run
all our websites over HTTPS,
in terms of security and privacy and tracking
and various other things.
But it does mean that when the passwords are in transit,
when we're sending details from a browser to a server,
they're a lot more secure ready than
they might have been in the past where
it was possibly commonplace for less security,
strict web applications to encrypt those passwords
in transit.
But we still have an issue when it's at rest
or before it's even sent.
So if there's a malicious plugin in your browser,
or there's a cross site scripting attack in the application,
then the password could be intercepted
before it's even sent to the server.
And once it's at the server, if it's not hashed properly
or there's a disgruntled employee who leaks the data,
or a hacker who gets in and leaks the data,
there are all sorts of ways that passwords can be leaked.
And we're all probably familiar with the,
Have I Been Pwned website,
which is run by a fellow Australian,
basically a database of a whole lot of large data breaches
and passwords that have been leaked,
so that people are able to find out
whether or not they've been affected by this,
but the pure existence of Have I Been Pwned
points to the fact that passwords are really,
are not a very secure credential mechanism
for us to use nowadays.
So we tend to layer it,
let's have a look at a different kind of credential
that we can use.
The SMS's, we've mentioned SMS's and emails a little already,
they're basically in the same kind of bucket,
it's a message that gets sent to you somehow,
and you can act on that message,
maybe you get sent a six digit code,
or a four digit code or a password
or some sort of one time password.
Or maybe it's the link that you click on.
And that link will die once you've clicked on it,
but it'll verify that you have access to the device
or the email account that that message was sent to.
So in terms of remembering and really,
it's quite easy to remember,
in fact, there is nothing to remember,
you need to have your phone on you
or access to your email account.
But then that one time code is something you type in
or the link of something you click.
It's ideally one time
so that nobody else can then use it in the future.
But there's nothing actually to remember.
It's also gonna be quite hard to guess,
because it's gonna be a random code each time.
And the the URL is going to be randomized each time ideally.
So in terms of hard to guess, easy to remember,
scores pretty highly.
Changing is about as easy as a password
or maybe a little harder.
Essentially, it's just an email address or phone number
in a database field.
But we need as developers,
when we're looking at the security side of things,
to take extra precautions when changing a password.
When changing an email address, rather or an SMS,
in that, we need to make sure that
if they change their phone number, for example,
we send the user a message to the new phone
to make sure they actually have access to it.
We might also want to send a message their old phone number
saying, hey, somebody just changed your phone number.
So that if it was somebody
who's not supposed to be changing this,
that the original users made aware of it.
And the same counts emails as well,
we're changing our email or phone numbers
or any kind of communication endpoints
and mechanisms for the website to get in touch with us.
We need to both verify
that we have access to the new account
and the old account needs to be told
that the change has been made.
In terms of intercept,
it's gonna be harder to intercept than a password.
But there are still a number of vulnerabilities.
So I'm not gonna put it into the green area,
there are issues with email, not with email itself per se.
But if somebody does have access to your email,
then they have access to pretty much any site
that uses email as a password reset mechanism.
So that puts us into a little bit of a dangerous territory,
when it comes to SMS is the SM protocol,
which is the mechanism used by the mobile carriers
around the world to make sure that SMS's get delivered
between networks.
The protocol itself has a couple of vulnerabilities,
which are not necessarily easy to perform.
But they do allow somebody for example, to say,
hey, I want to intercept an SMS going to Ben.
So I know Ben's mobile number,
I'm going to put in an S7 network attack
to have any messages sent to Ben come to me instead.
And in fact, maybe you could even set it
to send Ben a different response,
or still the same response.
So there's nothing out of the ordinary,
but intercepts are possible.
So, in this case, it's a targeted attack,
they have to specifically say,
we want to attack that phone number, one case of an email,
they'd have to attack a certain email address,
unless the passwords come up in a password leak,
such as through how have I been pwned?
So there are a number of issues.
But certainly intercepts are harder than pure passwords.
So I've scored it slightly higher,
you can probably see that is slightly more towards the green
area there, slipping in the middle of the gray area.
Then we've got voice or biometrics,
maybe it's a fingerprint.
The advantage with these types of credentials,
the biometric credentials is,
I don't remember the last time I left home
without my fingerprint, or without my voice.
Obviously, there are things that can change them.
And from using that as a pure credential mechanism
or as a sole credential mechanism--
my fingerprint can get damaged if I'm doing woodwork,
my voice get damaged if I I'm singing a lot,
not that I sing very much, but maybe I've have had a cold,
and my voice has changed.
So there are various things that can change
the credential, essentially.
But it's not really something I have to remember,
so in terms of easy to remember, hard to clone,
or hard to emulate.
I'm gonna score it pretty highly.
In terms of changing however, it's nigh on impossible,
I can't change my fingerprint.
I do have 10 fingerprints,
so I can definitely I can technically change
which fingerprint I use to authenticate nine times,
but then I'm out of fingers.
I can't go beyond that.
And also, once one fingerprint has been leaked,
I need to make sure that it's never used anywhere else
because I can't change, I can't invalidate this fingerprint.
If somebody has a fingerprint,
and I'll talk about how that could happen in a second.
We can't change it, I can't change my voice.
It changes slightly over time.
That's a different issue.
But I can't say, look, my voice has been compromised,
I need a different one.
That's not possible.
In terms of except, I'm scoring it quite highly,
but it's not quite in the green area.
Because there are a couple of little issues.
We know nowadays and you might have seen it yourselves,
some of these videos with a side and side video
where there's some gentleman [inaudible] public talking.
And then on the other side,
there's an artificially intelligently created video
of let's say, for example, Barack Obama, and it's his face,
his lips are moving in time to the words,
and the words are coming out in his voice.
And that's all computer generated
using artificial intelligence
based on what this person over here is saying.
So technically, it's possible to emulate voice.
Technically, it's possible to also emulate fingerprints.
There's another story where somebody was able to take
a high resolution photo of a  fingerprint on a glass
and taking that high resolution photo
into a 3d rendering software, turning into a 3d model
and then printing it with a 3d printer using a material
that was accepted by the fingerprint scanner as skin,
they were able to unlock a mechanism using
a cloned fingerprint.
So it's technically possible but in both of these cases,
there are getting targeted attacks like the SMS situation,
you have to, you can only emulate one voice at a time.
You can't just break all voices,
you have to find the fingerprint that you need to unlock.
So they're targeted attacks,
the Intercept is performs well in terms of,
it's hard to intercept.
But it is still possible, and we need to remember that.
And you've probably noticed that
there are three main characteristics here of password types.
And we call this multi-factor authentication.
We have passwords, which is something that you know,
something in your head. We have SMS's or emails,
which is something you have,
you have access to the email account,
or you have the SIM card that's in your phone.
And then we've got voice and fingerprint,
which is something that you are,
it's a biometric authentication mechanism.
So in order to make users more secure,
we now tend to look towards multi-factor authentication
where we need at least two, possibly three
of these characteristics.
You can't have two password types
or two something's you know,
you have to have one from each of these three columns.
And they could be things like a pin number,
an access card and a client certificate in the browser.
But having a client certificate isn't something you are,
but it's actually something you have.
But you could have a voice, for example, still.
So getting multiples of these factors make us more secure.
And the downside to that, though, is that
we're making it less convenient for people to log in,
we're putting extra layers of security in,
which makes convenience harder,
and people are going to be slightly more annoyed
at having to log in.
So we have to balance the user experience journey here
with proving who we are as users.
So what you'll find is that maybe
to access the system in the first place,
you just need a username and password,
and that'll get you in, you can see your dashboard.
Perhaps if it's internet banking, for example,
you can see your statements.
But if you want to do a transfer then,
you've got to give it a second factor of authentication.
Maybe they'll send you a code via SMS,
or maybe if it's a physical presence
you're trying to log into,
you'll need to use your fingerprint scanner
to access whatever it is you're trying to get to.
So we can do this step up authentication,
where higher levels of authentication are required
for more sensitive actions that we want to take.
Let's consider not using passwords
or anything that you know at all,
you might have heard of the term passwordless.
This is where we get rid of the need to remember things.
Obviously, you need to remember your phone
or your hardware authenticator.
But the need to remember things in your brain
in terms of what was my password, and when did I change it?
These kind of things are thrown out
when we look at passwordless.
And if we look at just things that we are
and things that we have,
we can get passwordless authentication,
which is a lot more convenient,
people that need to remember things.
If you're using a different computer
and you have a password manager,
you don't need access to your password manager anymore.
So we're making it easier for people to log in.
But now we're also
reducing the number of factors that we can use.
So if we go purely passwordless, convenience is high.
And we've still got good levels of authentication,
and credential checking.
But we've lost one of the factors that we can use.
So technically, maybe you could consider
that it's getting slightly weaker,
for the sake of slightly more convenience,
so ease of use for our users.
So let's bring in the FIDO security key now.
And that's the, things like these little
USB devices or your mobile phones
that have a hardware authenticator built in.
These are what WebAuthn uses for authentication.
The advantage with these,
is that they have a public-private key onboard,
which means that the credentials are always stored,
or the mechanism for identifying yourself
is contained within the key itself.
This makes it really easy to use or really hard to guess,
the public-private key pair, the only way of generating
a signature of a payload
--and we'll look into the technicalities of how WebAuthn works
in a minute--
but the ability to clone a public-private key pair
is mathematically improbable.
I'm not gonna say it's impossible,
there's probably some minuscule probability
that somebody somewhere might be able to do this.
But again, it would have to be a targeted attack,
it's gonna take a huge amount of computing resources,
so we can essentially call it impossible.
For most intents and purposes,
it's impossible to clone a public-private key pair
for the purposes of breaking a FIDO security key
sign-in mechanism.
In terms of changing,
it's about as easy to change as changing your phone number
or your email address on a website,
you just register a new FIDO security key
with a web application you're trying to log into.
And if you need to, you can de-register the old one.
Often, you might find that it's useful
for your users to have multiple keys anyway,
because then if they lose one, they've got a backup,
maybe they have one in their pocket
or on their key chain, and one in a safe somewhere
just in case something goes wrong.
And that way, they can use either of them to log in,
and they have a backup mechanism.
Because the ability to recreate like I say,
the public private key pair is so mathematically improbable
that if they lost their key,
they've lost their credential mechanism.
In terms of intercept, again, really high
and there's an additional thing that I'm gonna add on.
Like I say, generating public-private key pair
or cloning it, it is so improbable
that you're not going to be able to clone
the public-private key pair.
Similarly, when the signed challenges
which we'll look at in a second
and the keys are passed around,
the public key is the only one that ever leaves
the FIDO security key.
So, public keys are public,
it doesn't matter if there leaked,
and the signed challenge
is only good for one request anyway.
So intercept, even if you could intercept the data,
it doesn't matter because it's a single purpose, single use,
and it can't be used against
the wrong web application you're trying to look into.
And this is a really important additional feature,
is that it eliminates phishing attempts.
You might find, and we'll have a look at phishing,
actually how it works in a second.
But you might find that if you're,
if you provide credentials to the wrong application,
then obviously that malicious user
is going to be able to use that data,
the credentials to log in as you,
phishing is is how that works.
Let's have a look at that, in fact.
So you've got a user, let's say this is you
trying to have a lovely day watching videos
at JSConf Korea.
And you get an SMS or you get an email at some point.
And I had one of these emails just the other day,
it was from Google and they said,
"You've run out of cloud storage,..."
"...we're not able to backup your device anymore...."
"...Click here to upgrade your your account to get more storage."
Let's say you've got one of those.
But it wasn't actually from Google,
let's say it was from,
let's say, I was trying to get into your Google account.
I sent you the the message.
But it actually took you to a website that looks
very much like Google.
And to your brain,
it felt like you're logging into Google
and all the messaging felt right.
So you just clicked on it, and you get this login page,
and you provide your actual credentials to this website.
But your brain doesn't notice
the the domain is actually slightly different.
So you provide these credentials.
And the first thing I'm going to do as an attacker
is I'm going to send you to a fake success page,
I could send you to the actual Google website.
And the likelihood is if you're a Google user,
because you're logged in,
then you're probably actually logged in already.
So you'd get to the Google website
after I redirect you there.
And it would look like you've successfully logged in.
But there's a reason I'm using a fake success page.
We'll come back to that in a second.
Meanwhile, you've sent your actual Google credentials to me,
or more likely to a script that I've got running somewhere.
And that script is then going to take those credentials
and pass them to the Google server and say,
"Hey, I want to log in with this username and password
to see whether or not they work."
And in an ideal situation, what happens is,
I get a 200 confirmed it's okay, yes, you're logged in.
And I now have access to your Google account.
I can change your credentials and hijack your account
or I could use your account for fake reviews
or whatever it is that I want to do
with your Google details, I now have your credentials.
Now, let's go back to the fake success page for a second.
You might be aware
that if I did try to log into your Google account,
and Google's probably going to notice
and all of the larger websites
and any of the websites out there that
will check where you're logging in from
will alert you if you're logging in from a system
that has not been recognized.
So you might get a message on the browser,
if you're doing with legitimately saying "Hey,"
"it looks like you're logging in from a new device"
"or from a new country, we're going to send you an SMS,"
"please enter your code in here"
to verify that you are who you say you are.
This is the step of authentication
that we were talking about before.
Maybe it's a push notification,
we're sending a push notification, hit the yes button,
and then we'll log you in.
So if that happens to me while I'm trying to log in as you
then if you get the push notification, you hit 'yes' ,
I'm logged in. If you get the SMS,
where do you put the code?
So if I give you a fake success page that says,
hey, I need this code, you type your code in,
then I have your code, I can use that to login.
And the likelihood is, if in your brain you think
you're logging into the real Google website,
and you get the notification saying, "hey,"
"it looks like somebody"
"is trying to log into your Google account."
You're gonna hit yes without noticing.
But down at the bottom it says
"You're logging in from Melbourne, Australia",
which is me, not you.
So basically what phishing is
is the ability to trick somebody
to provide their credentials into a fake login page.
Let's have a look at how WebAuthn's
registration and the login process work now,
and how they stop the fake login page scenario or phishing,
from happening.
So let's say this is you
and you're trying to log into my website,
you go to your browser,
you type in the URL for my website,
you hit the Register button, and you say,
I want to create a new account.
My name is Susan.
So you provide the username Susan to my server,
my server says,
hey, it looks like you're trying to create a new account
using FIDO or using WebAuthn.
So what I'm going to do is I'm going to return to you,
or rather to your browser,
I'm going to send you a challenge.
And this is some randomly generated code,
some texts and some data that I require
a signed response for.
Let's have a look at that signature happens.
So the data gets sent to the browser.
The browser then uses the `navigator.credentials` API,
which is the API available in the newer browsers
to enable WebAuthn.  And this `navigator.credentials` API
has two methods on it.
The first one that we're gonna look at
is the create or as a number of methods.
But the first one we'll look at is the `create` method.
And into it, we pass the challenge
that got sent from the server.
And also we pass in the web origin.
So if you're looking at google.com, it'll say google.com.
If you're looking at g00gl3.com,
it'll have that in the web origin.
So each key pair is now locked into the domain.
And no matter how confused your brain might be,
your browser is never going to get confused
about the web origin that gets sent to the,
as part of the WebAuthn and login process.
So that web origin is used by the security key
to generate a new public-private key pair,
locks to that web origin,
and then it will take the challenge that it received as well
and it will use the private key to sign the challenge
and then it will return just that signed challenge
and the public key back to the browser.
The private key gets stored on the security key
on the actual device and only the public key
gets sent back to the browser,
along with a public key identifier or a key pair identifier
and the sign to challenge.
The browser doesn't do anything with this
other than send it straight onto the server.
So when Susan has created her account,
the final response to the server
includes the the public key,
or rather the public key ID and the signed challenge.
So my server can now say,
hey, I know that Susan tried to create an account,
and I know that I sent her browser this challenge,
and I've just received this signed challenge in return
which I can verify
is a signed version of the original challenge.
And it's also been signed with the key pair
that's associated with this public key that's come back.
So essentially, this is now in effect,
my password, it's the way that I verify
that Susan is the person who's logging in next time.
So into my database, I'll store Susan's username,
the public key and the public key ID,
they're the three bits of information that I need to store.
So now Susan comes back and she wants to log in.
She's got an account already.
And she says hey, my username is Susan, I want to login.
And my server is now gonna say,
well, I know that there is a user called Susan already,
and in effect, Susan's got this public-private key pair ID
that I'm aware of.
So I'm now going to send back to Susan's browser,
the challenge, and also the ID
of the public-private key pair that I expect
her to sign this challenge with, and return back to me.
So I need to make sure that she has
the same key available to her
that was used when she registered her account.
So we now call the `get` method
on the `navigator.credentials` API.
And into that, again, we pass the challenge,
we pass the web origin,
and we also pass in the ID this time.
So the hardware authenticator
can now pull out the public-private key pair
or rather the private key associated with that ID.
We can use that private key to sign the challenge
that got sent in, and then return
just that signed challenge.
The sign challenge goes back to the browser,
and the browser then returns that signed challenge
back to the server.
So in logging in, Susan told me her username,
I sent a challenge plus an ID,
that ID referenced the public private key pair
that was used to sign the challenge,
which is then returned back to the server.
And I can verify that the signed challenge that came back
is a signed version of the challenge
that I sent for the login process,
which will be different to the one that was used
for the registration process.
But I can also verify that it was signed with a key pair
that matches the public key that I have on record already.
So I'm not updating that,
I'm using the previously stored public key to verify
that the signature was generated by the same device.
So it's essentially proving that the person who's logged in
has access to the hardware authenticator,
which in the case of some hardware authenticators
might just prove that they have possession.
But in the case of ones where, like the Pixel 2,
where you have the fingerprint reader on the back,
or maybe the MacBook Pro,
where you need to talk to the fingerprint scanner
to activate the hardware authenticator.
It also proves who's there,
because while you don't know what the fingerprint is,
you know that it was the same person
who was able to unlock the key the first time.
So I hope that's given you a bit of an insight
into how WebAuthn works, how the flow works,
how we manage to eliminate phishing attacks
through the tying of the web origin
to the public-private key, and how it makes us as developers
more secure, the applications we develop more secure.
Insofar as we don't have to store credentials
in our databases anymore,
--we're actually just storing a public key,
which we can use to verify future signatures
generated by the hardware authenticators
that are used in the WebAuthn login flow.
I'm gonna be sticking around after this for Q&A.
I'm more than happy to take any questions.
And I'd also love to show you a demo using webauthn.me,
which is a website written by one of my colleagues.
I'm also available on Twitter, my DMs are open,
here's my email address.
I'd love for you to get in contact with me afterwards.
Connect with me via LinkedIn.
I'd love to hear your stories
about the kinds of problems you're trying to solve,
and just to generally connect. Thank you for your time
and I'll talk to you in the Q&A. Thanks.